johnny depp is taking shots at amber
heard in his music nearly a month after
winning his defamation case against her
do you find that mr depp has proven all
the elements of defamation
answer yes
the sunday times got an advanced listen
of johnny's new album with jeff beck and
according to their review some of the
lyrics are seemingly targeted at his
ex-wife
the times reports that johnny wrote two
original songs for the album
one titled sad mother effin parade where
the actor sings you're sitting there
like a dog with a seven year itch of
course a seven year itch is a belief
that romance in a marriage dwindles
around the seven year mark johnny and
amber divorce after 15 months
in the same song johnny also sings if i
had a dime it wouldn't reach your hand
fans think this lyric refers to depp's
lawyer's claims that his legal battle
against amber was never about money this
case is about telling you his story and
the truth about what really happened it
is about
restoring his lost reputation
fans will get to hear the full track
soon johnny and jeff's new album titled
18 is set to be released july 15th when
i was a kid all i dreamed about was
becoming a famous rock star or you know
this i don't know
this great musician
johnny's been living that rock star
dream joining jeff on tour check out
johnny showing off his guitar skills
performing a cover of marvin gaye's
what's going on
[Music]
and since the trial ended last month
johnny's main focus has seemingly been
his music on june 1st the jury ruled in
johnny's favor awarding him 15 million
in damages deciding he was in fact
defamed by amber's 2018 op-ed in the
washington post shortly after the
verdict was announced a source told e.t
he's looking forward to his future
especially his career i've gained some
degree of success in this industry i
mean i'm really it's it's been it's been
very
been very good to me and it's been very
good for me the source added johnny is
feeling really good and positive
he feels like things are on the upswing
for him and like he cleared his name
he's looking forward to the future both
personally and professionally and feels
like he got his career back
as for how amber's feeling well she's
ready to fight back her lawyer revealed
last month she intends to appeal we had
cameras in the courtroom so here we had
not only did we have a group of depp
fans that were there every day a hundred
were allowed in they lined up at one
o'clock in the morning for their
wristbands to be in that courtroom but
we had everything on camera and we had
tremendous social media that was very
very very much against amber very was
pointed out that that was the first time
that a victim of sexual abuse had to
testify on live television and i fought
hard and lost that battle
it should not have happened
at the time a separate source told et
that amber is feeling more optimistic
and is confident that her side will come
out eventually
[Music]